The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, let me say the
big idea for LQR trees again,
and you can tell me where
you want more details.
So here's the basic story.
I've got some goal
I want to get to,
and I've got a
lot of potential--
I'd like to be able to get there
from every initial condition,
let's say.
The idea was we
know how to design--
we know how to
stabilize trajectories.
So let's just pick
a point at random,
design a path to
the goal like that,
design the LTV LQR
stabilizer on this.
The great thing about
that is, first of all,
that it will locally
stabilize the trajectory,
but second of all, because
we can compute not only--
because we are given both
u equals some time varying,
we have a feedback
policy from that,
but we're also given an
estimate of the cost to go,
which is in this
time varying matrix,
yeah, the Riccati
equation backwards.
Because of that, when
we're doing our LQR design,
we actually have
a good candidate
for a Lyapunov function for the
system around that trajectory.
So that's an
important observation,
that when we do LTV LQR on a
trajectory, we get both, OK.
Now this thing, for
the linear system, even
the linear time
varying system, this
is a true Lyapunov function.
From all initial
states, this function
will just only get
smaller with time, OK.
But since the actual
system is non-linear,
as I get further
from my trajectory,
some of the non-linearity
is going to come in
and corrupt my
Lyapunov function.
At some point, when I get far
enough from the trajectory,
those higher order
terms are going
to mean that this thing
doesn't have a negative time
derivative.
But what I care about
for a Lyapunov function
is that this thing is
less than or equal to 0.
So the idea with
the certificates
is to do a higher order
polynomial expansion
of the dynamics
along this trajectory
and try to estimate
the threshold where
this stops being true, OK.
And that gives me,
essentially, a funnel.
If I do it everywhere
in time, that gives me
a funnel along the trajectory
over which I know the LQR
cost to go is a
Lyapunov function
for the nonlinear system.
And it's mostly conservative.
The way that we
construct that threshold
is mostly conservative.
The only weakness
of it-- meaning
the real basin of
attraction should be bigger
than this estimate.
The only weakness
is that I'm only
doing it by doing a polynomial
expansion of the system here.
So if there was a hard
discontinuity right next
to the trajectory
that didn't show up
in the Taylor expansion,
then I wouldn't ever see it.
I'm not exhaustively
searching the non-linearity
around the trajectory.
I'm just saying, along
this trajectory, what
are the higher order expansion?
I do a Taylor expansion-- a
third order, fourth order,
whatever it takes, and
I use that to check when
it breaks the cost to go, OK.
So that's the certificate.
That's just, if I have
a single trajectory,
that I can use this.
The real cool thing is that
thanks to Pablo and [? Sasha ?]
[? McGretzky, ?] we can do
that efficiently with a convex
optimization.
And then the idea is, if I can
do it for a single trajectory,
then why not put
that back into sort
of an RRT kind of
framework and try
to build lots of trajectories
that are stabilized?
OK, so the first step was just
to pick a point at random,
design a single trajectory.
The second step is, let's
pick a new random point.
I don't actually have to go
all the way back to my goal.
I just have to go to the nearest
point on the current tree
and stabilize that.
And then I pick another
point, find the nearest
point on the tree, build
the trajectory in like that,
stabilize that.
If I pick a new point
and it's already
in the basin of attraction,
I don't need to add an edge.
That would be a
waste of my time.
So the effect is I get these--
I didn't say carefully
what the results are,
because I can't prove them yet.
This is still hot off the press.
But I think that I can say that
it probabilistically covers
the reachable state space.
Every place that I can
get to the goal from,
there exists a controller.
If I design enough
samples, I should
be able to get to
the goal, given I
do enough steps in my LQR tree.
So as time goes to
infinity, the entire space
will be covered with basin of
attraction of a controller that
gets me to the goal, which is
a pretty powerful thing to say,
if you're willing to wait
till time goes to infinity.
And the practical thing
that's nice about it is it
seems to happen pretty
quick with a handful
of-- with a fairly small
number of trajectories.
Yeah? [? John. ?]
AUDIENCE: If you want
to guarantee [INAUDIBLE]
[? in your ?] system has that,
which property would you have
[? to let it ?] sample inside
the basins of attraction?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah,
so that's why I
have to qualify the guarantees.
I'm only saying the
nonlinear system
as represented as
the Taylor expansion
around the trajectories.
That's the weakness.
So it really only works
for smooth systems.
If there's a cliff here and I
design a trajectory right here,
it might come up with [? a ?]
saying a basin of attraction's
here, even though
that's just not true.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: If I
smooth the cliff--
[? sorry, John. ?] If I smooth
the cliff and therefore,
when I Taylor expand here, I can
see that there's a cliff there,
then I'd like to think that the
certificates would do the right
thing.
But if it's a hard cliff where
the higher order expansion here
doesn't see that cliff,
then there's no hope.
AUDIENCE: [? If ?] [? you ?]
[INAUDIBLE] inside the basin,
[? though, ?] couldn't
you [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
a good question.
So it's just building
more and more accurate
certificates as time
goes to infinity.
It could be.
It could be a good idea.
My suspicion is
that, in practice,
this is going to be good enough
for-- and we're not going
to want to do the--
maybe I'm just the kind of
guy that cuts the corners,
but I think this is a
pretty good solution.
Ernesto.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? basin ?] [? of attraction ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I use--
whenever I design
each trajectory,
I use [? DR ?]
[? call. ?] Why not?
But it's so I could say they're
locally optimal in the branches
that they are, just because
that's easy to accomplish.
But there's no sense in
which it's globally optimal.
So I just try to say that
every state will eventually
get there and not that
it'll get there optimally.
mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: But again, if
you allowed it to sample
inside the basins
of attraction, you
would probabilistically get
some kind of convergence
to global optimal.
RUSS TEDRAKE: There are ways
to try to get at that problem.
I don't think it's a one-step
change from what I said.
I think you have to
do something more.
I mean, any one of
these trajectories--
maybe that's getting busy.
Any one of those trajectories
is just locally optimal.
So let's consider the case
where the goal is here.
There's something
here, and I did this.
And for some reason,
I got a trajectory
like that, which is
locally optimal but not
globally optimal, because
there's a shorter path here.
So I need to somehow--
I would need to somehow
include the mechanism, which
is, I think, what
you're getting at,
to eventually find a different
path to the same place
and overwrite the old path.
And I don't have any
mechanism for that inside.
And it turns out
to-- that's actually
what I was going for initially.
Turns out to be a little
bit nontrivial to do.
Chris Atkeson has
a nice idea that
goes towards doing
that a little bit more
on composing
trajectory libraries.
But I gave up
optimality and tried
to get coverage with a basin
of attraction in that design.
So some of you have been
talking to me about the projects
and have been asking
about these things.
So I think Mark and Matt
are thinking about trying
to help with this--
I mean, this is new.
I mean, you guys can
definitely help with the idea.
So we're trying to
figure out, for instance,
if there's actuator limits.
These guys are talking
about trying to figure out
how to compute the certificates,
and even the LQR stabilizer,
if you not only have a
quadratic [INAUDIBLE] on u
but have some hard limits on
u, because that's a problem we
actually hit in practice.
So one of the final projects
in the class, I think,
is going to be
helping with that.
There's problems of, how do
you design the stabilizer
through impacts and
in periodic systems.
There's lots of good questions.
So if you're excited
about that idea--
I'm definitely excited
about the idea right now--
then I'll see what
you wrote up today,
but we could maybe try to
find a way to connect that.
I'd be thrilled to have
your help in making
that idea more relevant.
Yeah?
OK.
Does that cover?
Now for something completely
different, although related,
of course.
So in the LQR trees and
basically in everything
that we've done so
far in class, we've
made a handful of
important assumptions.
The most important
one, probably,
is we've always assumed that we
have the model of the system.
So next week we're
going to get at,
how do you do some of
these optimizations
when you don't even
have a model, OK.
We've also assumed so far that
the current state of the system
is known.
In other words, the state of
the robot is fully observable.
If I stop assuming
that, we start
getting into discussions
about state estimation,
and we will towards
the end of the class.
And there's another
assumption we've been making,
which is that the dynamics
are deterministic,
let's say, that pretty
much, the system goes
where I think it's going to go.
Now I chose to write that
and then cross it out,
because that's not quite
what we're assuming, OK.
I want to write that.
But maybe what's
a-- if we really
were assuming that the
dynamics were deterministic,
then we wouldn't have been
spending much time talking
about feedback at all.
We would have been just
focused on open loop things.
So let's think.
Let's have a short
philosophical argument
about what we're
actually doing, yeah?
So we're not quite assuming
that it's deterministic.
Maybe a better way to
describe what we're doing
is we're assuming something
specific about the disturbances
in the system.
We're assuming that
disturbances look
like a change in
initial conditions.
That's one way to say
it, an un-modeled change
in initial conditions.
By virtue of talking about
these feedback stabilizers,
the motivation is that, OK,
I'm following this trajectory.
When the model's
right, all is good.
If something does
happen, then OK,
it's going to move me
somewhere in state space.
But as long as that's in
the basin of attraction--
the whole idea of really
a basin of attraction
is going at the idea that
I can handle disturbances
by just being robust in state.
But that's actually a
subtle thing to assume.
I want to be a little bit more
explicit about what that means.
Really, it sort of
implies that we're
assuming that disturbances
are impulsive, not constant,
instantaneous, Impulsive.
If a disturbance
for my walking robot
was someone put a
new weight on my leg,
then that's not something
that our designs so far have
handled, because that's
more like the model changed.
We're talking about
something that it moved me,
and now I have to deal with it.
So if the disturbance
lasts for a long time,
then that actually feels a
lot more like a model change.
But if it's impulsive,
I can think of it
as a change in
initial condition.
And the other thing that
that implicitly assumes
is that the
disturbances are rare.
If I got impulsive disturbances
1,000 times a second, then,
again, my completely
deterministic analysis
isn't probably the
relevant one, OK.
So those are-- implicitly, we've
been making these assumptions
the whole time.
The whole idea of talking
about basins of attraction
of deterministic systems
and doing feedback design
implicitly makes
that assumption.
So there's three
things there, the fact
that it's un-modeled and
impulsive and rare, I guess.
If your disturbances are
not instantaneous rare
disturbances, then I think
I would advocate quickly
for starting to think
about your dynamics
as not deterministic dynamics
but as a stochastic dynamics,
OK.
And even if they are
impulsive and rare,
but if you have a
model of them, then
you should still be able to do
better by explicitly letting
your feedback design reason
about the stochastic dynamics,
OK.
So today I want to
start talking about--
I want to start breaking
down our assumptions.
And throughout the
rest of the class,
we're going to try
to break these down.
Let's start breaking
down the assumption
of deterministic dynamics, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] [? or ?]
talking about the LTV LQR.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
actually saw something,
like if we the actually have
this [? passive ?] transition
model and we move somewhere,
and then we're a little bit off
from the trajectory, then
you look at the policy,
which would bring this back
[INAUDIBLE] [? projected ?]
[? and ?] go back.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think the
answer to your question is yes.
So one of the things we're going
to do today is show that the--
it's sort of subtle
that that's yes.
But anybody who knows linear
quadratic Gaussian control,
yeah, well, it turns
out that we're actually
doing linear quadratic
Gaussian control,
but that's a
surprising result, OK.
So in the specific case
of linear dynamics,
quadratic cost, Gaussian noise,
then what you said is true.
So that's a special case
that we'll see quickly.
But in general, it's not true.
Right, so and again, this
is leading into next week.
We're going to start
talking about doing
these optimal controlled
derivations without any model.
But today let's think
about what happens
if we have a stochastic model.
OK, lots of ways people--
there's lots of
different notations
people use to talk about
stochastic dynamics.
The one I'll use is, I
think, the most popular one.
We still got our standard
equations of motion,
but we're going to add an
additional input, which
is some disturbance w
as an additional input
into our dynamics, where w
of t is some noise process.
OK, but if we let the noise
come in through an input here,
then we can still think about
it as a deterministic function,
our dynamics as a
deterministic function,
and keep it mostly the same as
what we've been thinking about.
Now some people don't like
defining noise processes
in continuous time.
It's a little bit more
natural to describe them
in discrete time, and as
we've done in the other class,
let's do the discrete
time case first.
So in discrete time,
we'll do the same thing.
But now maybe we can--
it's easier to think about
what w of n might be.
So for instance, w of n might
be some iid Gaussian process
or something like that, which
is just a complicated way
to say that at each n, w
n is sampled independently
from a Gaussian.
Let's say a normal distribution,
like something like that.
So when I'm simulating
this in MATLAB, if I have--
I can simulate an
iid Gaussian process
by just every time step
calling rand n, yeah, as if--
and it's independent from the
[? w's ?] I picked before.
That's a pretty good model.
Now one thing I want to
avoid talking about today
so far is, let's still assume
that we have perfect state
information.
So I don't want to worry
about sensor noise yet.
It turns out it'll be
pretty natural to think
about it with some
of the same tools,
but let's just assume for
now that when I'm in state x,
I know I'm in state x exactly.
But if I'm trying
to think about,
into the future,
what's going to happen,
what's the optimal thing to do,
I have to worry about the fact
that the noise in the system
is going to push me around.
OK, so we updated
our dynamic equation.
We better start--
if we're thinking
about this in an
optimal control sense,
we better also update our
definition for optimality.
So it used to be that we said
J in the discrete time case
was just some sum from n
equals 0 to n of g xn un.
The problem with that
now is that xn, this
is going to be-- this is
now a random process, yeah?
If I run from the same
initial conditions
with even the same
open loop tape,
let's say, the
system five times,
this is going to be a different
value every time I run it.
Exit time three will
be different every time
I run it, OK, which
means J is also
going to be a random
variable, a random.
So it doesn't quite make sense
to say my notion of optimality
is some random variable.
We want to choose a property
of that random variable
that we care about.
There's different
schools-- again,
being philosophical
a little bit,
there's different schools of
thought in control theory.
Some people say the thing
you should care about,
the only thing you
should worry about
is the worst case behavior.
You want to worry about the
tails of your distributions
and make absolutely
sure that my plane--
if I'm riding on a plane
from here to California,
it's not going to
fall out of the sky
with five nines of
probability or something, OK.
I actually don't subscribe--
OK, when I'm riding on a plane,
I do subscribe to that, OK.
But when I'm building
robots that I
don't have to put my
life in jeopardy for,
I don't believe in that.
And I actually don't
think animals do that.
I think if animals
were so conservative--
so that's the robust control
approach, what I just
described, worrying
about the worst case.
And the problem with robust
control, the well documented,
well discussed problem
with robust control
is it tends to come up
with conservative control
strategies.
So if I'm worrying about
never running into the table,
then I'm never going to go
anywhere near that table.
There's another
approach, which I
prefer, that tends to be more
common in the optimal control
community, is to worry about
maximizing the expected
returns, OK.
So now let's define J as the
expected value of this cost
function.
There's a really obvious
reason why the optimal control
people choose to do that.
It's because we already made a
decision to do additive costs.
Expectations play
beautifully with summations,
and so our life is going
to stay clean and good
if we're willing to do the
expected value derivations, OK.
But also philosophically, I
think that me as an animal, I
maximize my expected reward.
Or a gazelle running
through the field, I think,
is maximizing expected reward.
I mean, on average, it's
doing spectacularly well.
And every once in a
while it wipes out
and falls down and breaks
its leg and gets eaten.
But if it was worrying
about that all the time,
then it would never
run as fast as it does.
So-- or as aggressively
as it does.
So I think,
personally, if you want
to build aggressive
robots, you've
got to stop worrying about
guarantees of stability,
of performance.
Just try to maximize
the average performance.
I think that's where
I've put my chips.
OK, so now, just to be
clear here, so x-- again,
every time I run it,
even with an open loop u,
if I completely
control u, so u is not
a random variable but
some open loop tape,
lets say, x will still
be a random variable, OK.
But J is not.
J is saying that,
given some control
policy, some initial
conditions, there
is a well defined cost that I--
expected cost that I receive.
And that's something
I can optimize, OK.
Does that make sense?
OK, so I want to think about
the implications of having
these things turn
into random variables
with a simple example, OK.
And that example I
like, the one I like
is a particle sitting in a bowl.
Let's say some particle
in a potential well.
So let's say gravity
is like this,
and I've got some
bowl I'm sitting in,
and this particle
is going to want
to roll down that bowl, OK.
But to make it
interesting, we're
going to say that this particle
is subject to Brownian motion.
Do you guys know what
Brownian motion is?
I guess-- was it--
I guess if you look down at a
Petri dish of very small things
and they don't
sit still, there's
debate about exactly the
physical mechanisms of it,
but phenomenologically, you
can see very small cells that
are not actively
motile by themselves
move around in a random
fashion, doing random walks
and things like this.
So people-- I won't get
into the philosophy of--
the philosophical debate
of whether there exists
stochasticity in the world,
but I think stochasticity
is certainly a relevant
model for a lot
of things we're doing here.
And I don't want to
get quantum in class.
OK, but let's just
say that this guy is
subject to the
dynamics of this bowl.
But on top of that
dynamics of this bowl,
it has a tendency to jitter
around a little bit, OK.
So I'll write down the dynamics.
I'll keep it discrete for now.
So let's say at every time
step, the difference--
the update looks like
the gradient of that bowl
it's trying to go down that
bowl plus some random noise.
I'll call it z of n.
And this, again, I'll assume
is iid, Independent Identically
Distributed Gaussian noise.
So if you've never taken a class
with all this random variables
and everything, I hope most of
this will still come through.
I'll throw a few of these words
and try to be soft about it.
If you have questions about
any of these, just ask me.
I think that we're
going to be able to say
things that are
fairly mechanically
intuitive and helpful.
So I hope it's
accessible to everybody.
And if it's not, ask me.
OK, so this is a reasonable
dynamical system now.
It's attempting
to, on each update,
having gone down the gradient
plus some random noise, OK.
Let's make our lives easier
by choosing u of x to be--
how about that?
That's pretty nice, right?
It makes our life good if
everything is quadratic.
Then this thing turns out
to be negative alpha x.
OK, so just to make sure
we're thinking about it,
if the noise is 0, then what's
going to happen in this system?
I've got a discrete
time system, which,
if I move that back
over to the other side
like we're accustomed
to, it goes like this.
So how does that thing behave?
Where's the fixed point?
At 0.
And when is it stable?
When's it stable?
Discrete time linear system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] equals
0 [? of 1 ?] but [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? positive ?] [? x? ?]
RUSS TEDRAKE: No, you're
thinking too continuous time.
In discrete time, your bounds on
your eigenvalues are between--
the absolute value has to be
less than 1, which I think,
in this case, means alpha has
got to be between 0 and 2,
yeah?
Everybody OK with that?
Yeah.
That wasn't supposed to be the
big insight for the lecture,
but.
OK, so the reason I
wanted to say that--
OK, so we definitely have
some stable dynamics pushing
us this way in this bowl.
The picture tells you that.
The math tells you that.
We have some stable dynamics
that's pushing us towards here,
and then we have something
that's pushing us out,
which is that noise.
If I was-- maybe just
as a thought exercise,
if my bowl had been
flat, if alpha was 0,
and I've got this thing
subject to Brownian motion,
then if I look at it at time
100, where's it going to be?
I mean, it could go
sort of anywhere, yeah?
If it's in this bowl and it's
subject to Brownian motion,
then where's it going
to be at time 100?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
close to [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: You'd expect
it, with high probability,
to be around here.
There's a chance--
I mean, even if it turns--
even with small noise, if I
were to get some abnormally rare
large force in this
direction 10 times in a row,
if I watched this Gaussian
process long enough,
I might look and find it here.
But that's going to be
very low probability.
So what I'd expect to
find is if I watch it
for some amount of
time, and I look at it,
and time is 100, that it's
probably going to be here.
Going to draw some
probability distribution here.
And sure, there's some tails
here that'll say if I looked,
maybe I'll find it there, but
that's pretty unlikely, OK.
So hopefully when we're
all done with this,
we're going to get that out.
And it's not too hard
to see it, actually.
So what's the best
way to say it?
So let's pretend that we're
going back to our-- so this
was the-- we're back
to the noise case
again, putting epsilon back in.
Can we compute, then-- so if
I know where I am at time n--
if my sensors are
perfect, like I
said, I know where
I am at time n,
where am I going to
be a time n plus 1?
So let me write that as some
probability distribution that--
I want to write, where
am I at time n plus 1
given I know where
I am at time n?
What's that going to look like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Gaussian function [INAUDIBLE]
1 minus [INAUDIBLE] n by
some variance, which is kind
of [? problematic, ?] actually.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
Right?
So probably, I'm going to be 1
minus alpha xn away from where
I was, but then some
Gaussian distribution
centered around that point.
The deterministic
part puts me here,
and this part then
adds noise to that, OK.
So that's going to
be my full Gaussian
here, 2 pi sigma squared e to
the negative xn plus 1 minus 1
minus alpha xn, that whole
thing squared, all over to sigma
squared, yeah?
You agree with that?
If I know where I am at
time xn, which, by the way,
is equivalent in
probability space
to saying I have a
delta function here--
I know where I am.
My probability distribution
is a delta function.
Then on the next step, I'm going
to be 1 minus alpha times that,
and I'm going to have
a distribution, which
is mean of this.
This is a Gaussian distribution
x minus mu over 2 sigma
squared, squared.
This is the new x.
This is mu.
Yeah?
Good.
So now we have everything
we need, really, to proceed.
So let's say I knew
where I was at x0.
On x1, I'm going to be at the
function described by this.
Where am I going to be at x2?
Well, in general, I
have to do the update.
And let me use the
notation P of n plus 1,
meaning the probability
distribution
over x at time n plus 1.
So think of it as a different
function at each discrete time.
Notationally, it's
the cleanest, I think.
Well, that's going to be--
it's going to be--
I have to think about--
oops, I did--
sorry, this is a y.
Yeah.
My fault.
So if I was--
I have to think about
all the possibilities.
I want the probability
that I was in y equals 0
and then the probability of
being in x, considering I
was in y0.
But also, I have to think
about, what if y was 1?
Well, what's the
probability of that?
And I'm going to sum the whole
thing up in a continuous way,
and I'm going to get
my new probability
of being at the new place.
You guys OK with this equation?
All right, I have to
consider all possible cases
of where I was at time n--
that's given by this--
and then apply my dynamics,
which was given by this,
to get my new distribution, OK.
Hope that's OK, but even if
it's not, it still should be--
you'll still be OK
here in a second.
So we can do that.
So let's say that P of
n y is a delta function.
That's what I said.
So I know my initial conditions.
I should have drawn it right
here to match that plot.
Well, then after
one step, it's going
to just pick out the P of this
Gaussian centered at that y.
And at one step,
then, I'm going to be
at a Gaussian
distribution 1 minus alpha
from where I was, centered
around 1 minus alpha
from where I was.
Now in the next step, I
have to consider the fact
that I could be anywhere
in that Gaussian,
weighted appropriately.
And I have to consider all
of the updates from those.
That's what this
integral is doing.
And it turns out the
magic of Gaussians
and linearity is that
if P of y is a Gaussian,
and I multiply it by another
Gaussian and integrate,
I get out a Gaussian.
Yeah.
Life is good.
So I'll leave the actual math
to your-- eh, what the heck.
I'll just-- what you get--
I can write the answer--
if you push a Gaussian
through, turns out
to be 1 over square root of
2 pi sigma squared integral
from negative infinity to
infinity of e to the negative--
let me actually write the--
skip that one line just
to keep things moving.
Let's do 1 over 1
minus alpha square root
of 2 pi sigma squared.
I have the probability of n at
y prime minus 1 alpha dy alpha,
where y is 1 minus alpha y.
It's just-- I haven't
done a lot of work yet.
I just changed
coordinates into y prime.
And it turns out, for
instance, if I look for a--
if I guess that the steady
state is a Gaussian form,
and I look for a place where
this and this can possibly
be the same function,
if I want to look
at the steady state
of this dynamics,
then I find that P
star of x is 1 over--
oh-- square root of
2 pi sigma 0 squared
e to the negative x
squared 2 sigma 0 squared.
It's a Gaussian.
It's actually a mean 0 Gaussian,
is the steady state of that
update, OK, which is just a
few lines in the notes, where
sigma 0 squared is
sigma squared, which
is the noise from the Brownian
motion minus alpha squared.
OK?
So I think, actually,
these equations
tell the entire story.
If I start my system
even from some--
well, specifically, if I start
my system in a delta function
or in a Gaussian distribution
of initial conditions,
then I'm going to be Gaussian
for the rest of time.
Turns out even if it's not,
it'll go to a stable Gaussian.
And if I watch--
if I look far enough
into the future,
at the steady state of that
probability distribution,
then it's actually going to
be what we hoped we'd find.
It's a mean 0 Gaussian.
This was 0 in my plot.
And its width, its variance is
given by two competing terms.
You've got the noise
from the Brownian motion
trying to push you out
into larger variance,
and you've got the
competing force
of the stability of the dynamics
pushing you back in, OK.
So if alpha gets--
and you actually--
this also is valid exactly
when alpha's between 0 and 2.
Doesn't go to 0 in
that regime yet.
OK.
So if I want to look at that
particle at time 100 or time
10,000, then I should
expect to see it
somewhere with probability
given by this distribution
in the vicinity of that 0, OK.
And that comes
out of simple math
of pushing this Gaussian
through this equation, OK.
Now you all probably-- most of
you probably knew that before.
Why do you know this before?
Maybe not in this level of
detail, but why do many of you
know this already?
It's a Kalman filter, right?
The Kalman filtered forward
process takes a Gaussian,
shoves it through a linear
system, stays Gaussian.
This is the single variable,
little more careful version
maybe than you'd do if you
call MATLAB's Kalman stuff.
But yeah, so that's not
a surprising result.
But I think it forces you to
think about a couple things.
So like I said, the
stability of the system
is critical in determining
that final distribution.
But even more
significantly than that,
there's some implications of
having noise in the system.
Implications of having
stochastic dynamics, OK.
If you want to
reason about the cost
that you're going
to incur, given
some policy, for
instance, in order
to reason about the
future dynamics,
even though you know
current state, so even given
initial conditions, you
have to reason about--
it's not enough to
just reason about x.
You have to reason about that
entire distribution, what
I called Pn of x, not just x.
OK, so as soon as we start
doing stochastic stuff,
we have to change our
view of the world.
The state x is
not the only thing
you care about moving forward.
You care about the probability
distribution of states
that you live in.
What would you say about the
stability of this system?
If I asked you, is that a stable
system, what would you say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? stable it ?] [? is ?]
[? or something? ?]
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm asking--
and we're going to
do that, but I'm
asking you for your intuition.
What would you guess?
Would you feel comfortable if
I said, it's a stable system,
let's move on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: In
some ways, it's OK,
because the
distribution is stable.
x is not stable, OK.
If I look at a-- if I'm at--
there's no fixed point in x.
The noise is going to
keep moving me around, OK.
But I told you that
P of x, actually--
well, I only told you
it's a fixed point,
but I can tell you it's
a stable fixed point.
P of x is actually stable, OK.
OK, so basically, this
equation right here,
this update right here, it's a
very famous, important thing.
Well, so important that it's
called the master equation,
yeah.
I mean, don't just
name it after some guy.
Call it the master equation.
And there are various versions
of the master equation
and specific problems
that are named
after people's last names,
but in general, it's
the master equation, OK.
So you can't forget
how significant it is.
And the idea is that
in the master equation,
you're looking at the
dynamics of the probability
distribution.
Not the dynamics
of a single state,
the dynamics of a
probability distribution, OK.
So that probability
distribution,
actually, in the master
equation, is stable, OK.
Now there are more
complicated cases, actually.
So what about this one?
What's this thing going
to do in the long run?
AUDIENCE: Bimodal distribution.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's going to
have a bimodal distribution
in the long run.
So it would be inappropriate
to say either of those points--
I mean, that either of those
points are fixed points.
For the deterministic
case, they are.
For the stochastic
case, they're not.
And you're right.
It's going to go to some
distribution like this, OK.
I have a decision point, which
of my 10 pages I should do.
I could talk about some examples
of just stochastic dynamics,
for instance, on
walking robots, or I
could get to the optimal control
of the more simple systems.
I have to set John
up for next week,
so I guess I got to just tell
you that, actually, we've
done some work thinking
about, for instance,
the rimless wheel--
I'll just tell you
the setup, and I
won't tell you all the details.
So here's a realistic example
of that sort of dynamics.
Take your rimless
wheel, OK, dynamics.
And let's say, instead
of walking down
some constant ramp,
let's say on every step,
the ramp angle is drawn
from some distribution.
OK, so this is passive walking
on rough terrain, mm-hmm.
And it turns out it's
not following a limit
cycle anymore.
But it's always-- its long-term
probability distribution is--
well, there's a slightly
more complicated story.
If I look long enough, this
thing has an absorbing state.
So if I take a big enough
step, then eventually,
I'm going to lose enough energy.
Remember, the deterministic
system had two fixed points.
One was standing still.
The other one was rolling
at a constant speed, OK.
The standing still fixed
point on rough terrain
is an absorbing fixed point.
If I get there and I
never take another step,
then I'm never going to
leave that fixed point.
So that is actually a
true fixed point, yeah.
The rolling fixed
point, you're going
to tend to bounce
around that fixed point.
So maybe this picture is
something more like this, yeah.
OK?
So the standing still fixed
point, if I get in there,
it's absorbing.
I'm never coming out.
But the rolling fixed point,
you tend to bounce around
this limit cycle, OK.
And then every once in a while,
in the stochastic dynamics
case, they say that
these particles
make an escape attempt--
that's what they call it.
OK-- and maybe shoot
over and fall down, OK.
And it's really very beautiful.
If you watch the
probability distributions
as they propagate
through the rimless wheel
equations, or the compass
gait equations or you name it,
then what you get is you
get this probability mass
around here.
For a long time,
it's pretty likely
that I'm in the vicinity
of that limit cycle.
And then slowly, as
the time goes on,
the escape attempts
continue to the point
where this thing gets
smaller and smaller
until, as time goes
to infinity, I'm only
going to be standing still, OK.
So the negative-- the
pessimistic view of that work
is to say that you're
always going to fall down.
You can build the
best robot you want,
but if you have a reasonable
model of the dynamics,
it's always going to fall down.
If you wait long enough, a Mack
truck is going to come along
and hit it or it's going
to walk into a door
or something like that.
You can do the best you want,
but it's going to fall down,
and it'll end up on
YouTube, probably, right?
[LAUGHTER]
So--
AUDIENCE: So you're assuming
your ramp distribution is
actually Gaussian?
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
what we decided, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: But
that doesn't actually
imply that the posterior is
Gaussian, because it's going
through nonlinear dynamics.
AUDIENCE: Right, but
I mean, in reality,
the random distribution
is never going
to be truly Gaussian, right?
Because--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Everything's
Gaussian if you get enough of--
I don't know.
I mean, I think that's--
so you want to do stairs
or something more specific?
AUDIENCE: Oh, well,
I'm just saying,
if there is a hard limit
on how steep your ramp is--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: --you could
guarantee that--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
Very good point.
All right, so of
the distributions
didn't have tails,
then there are
cases where I can bound
it never going over.
But those tails actually
have to be pretty steep--
the limitations have
to be pretty steep,
because you have to make
sure that, on a single step,
of the damping overcomes the
biggest possible perturbation.
If on a single-- if
your noise can ever
be bigger than what you can
take out in a single step,
then you will eventually,
as time goes to infinity,
find a way to get out.
Yeah?
So Katie Mill did some
nice work in quantifying
the metastable
dynamics of walking.
And actually, I think that--
so we call it the metastable,
because that distribution
is long-living.
It still makes sense
to talk about where
you'd expect this thing
to be while it's walking.
But eventually, we have to
admit it's going to be--
it's going to go
to falling down.
Like a diamond is a diamond
for a very long time,
but eventually, it'll
turn back into graphite.
OK, so good.
So there's actually
a beautiful--
even if you don't
care about control,
I think there's actually
beautiful things that
happen in stochastic dynamics.
But the thing that matters
here is, we've switched hats.
We've now started thinking
about probability distributions
and how they evolve
with dynamics,
and how we can change
those probability
distributions with control.
If I could if I could
control the shape of that,
then I can control those
probability distributions,
for instance.
OK.
So it turns out it's sort of
trivial to work stochastic--
to solve stochastic
optimal control problems,
at least with dynamic
programming, OK.
And it works out, because of
this additive cost structure,
that it's roughly
no more expensive
to solve the stochastic
optimal control
than the deterministic one.
And that matters.
Maybe I should even make
the point that it matters.
So if I have a
stochastic process--
and in general,
the optimal policy
that you get from
stochastic optimal control
is going to be different
than the one you
get from deterministic
optimal control,
so potentially,
in dramatic ways.
Let me try to make
that point here.
So imagine I've got my--
I've got a trashcan robot.
I shouldn't call it a trashcan.
I've got a-- what are they?
What are the names of
those little red robots?
Pioneer robot or
something like this, yeah?
And I want to get it from--
to this goal.
Let's say I've got a
cost function like this,
and I start over here.
And as I go, I know that
my wheels slip or something
like that.
My distributions are going
to grow as I go, yeah.
And I've got some
ability to control them,
so they're not going
to grow unbounded,
but let's say they're going to
grow in my path to the goal,
OK.
There'll be two
competing forces.
There'll be my ability
to measure and fight
against disturbances,
and there'll
be the inevitable disturbances.
And those two will again combine
into some sort of distribution
over time, OK.
Now imagine-- like the scenario
we talked about in the feedback
case, imagine my cost
function is 0 everywhere,
negative 1 at the goal--
I want to get to the goal--
and say something
really big here, yeah.
There's pits of fire in
the middle of the lab.
OK?
No, I mean, right, so we've
got to make the point.
If it was just 1, I wouldn't
make-- be as dramatic.
But OK, so long story short,
a stochastic optimal control
solution is unlikely to
choose this path, because 0--
even if the distributions
are fairly tight,
0 times a big part of the
probability distribution plus 1
e to the 6 times even a
little part of the probability
distribution is still
a big number, OK.
And so therefore, the expected
value of going through here
is that I'm going to
incur quite a bit of cost.
Does that make sense?
So if I just did
deterministic optimal control,
we talked about using
feedback to try to motivate
not going through there.
But really, the
more direct way is
to think about the
probability distributions.
So if I can control my
probabilities to the point
where I know 0 probability
is going to be in here,
then sure, go ahead
through there.
And the deterministic one
will probably find that.
But the stochastic one, if it
realizes there's something,
will probably try to find
a different path, OK.
So that's one example.
But in general, the stochastic
optimal control policies
are going to be different
than the deterministic ones,
and better.
If you have a reasonable
model of the disturbances
you'd expect to
encounter, then you
should allow your
optimal control tools
to think about them, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
stochastic environment s times 4
[INAUDIBLE] [? you have ?]
[INAUDIBLE] [? more states, ?]
because potentially, each
action can move you to any
of the possible states
while in deterministic case,
you can go to one state.
So when you do [INAUDIBLE]
[? worse ?] [? case. ?]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
I knew someone was going to--
so I would say essentially no.
I almost wrote, essentially no.
And the reason I want to make
that comparison, actually,
is because I want to
compare it directly
to the barycentric interpolation
that we were doing before,
which is what I'm going
to do in a second.
And that is already
doing an interpolation,
already going through some
probability, some transition
matrix, yeah.
And it's probably true
that the-- it may be true,
depending on your
noise distributions,
that if you add a lot of noise,
that transition matrix will
be more dense, and therefore,
it might take more time,
depending on how you computed.
My MATLAB implementation,
it's the same.
Yeah?
Is that fair?
And it's no more
complicated to write down.
How about that?
OK?
We'll completely
understand what [INAUDIBLE]
was asking in just a second.
OK, so why is it no
more complicated for me
to write down on the board
the stochastic optimal control
case in dynamic programming?
Remember, I said now this is--
I'm going to take the expected
value of my additive cost.
First let's just think about
what the implications are
for doing optimal control.
So first of all, I can take
that expectation inside.
And now what's the
probability of g--
or what's the expected
value of g at xn un?
Well, x has got
some distribution
given by P of x, and yeah.
So this thing is
going to work out
to be-- you can always take the
expected value of a function
of x by just that function times
its distribution integrated.
This thing's going
to work out to be
so an integral over all
possible states of g
of x u of n times P of n x dx.
Right?
OK, so you could imagine
computing optimal policies
by figuring out the state
distribution by that evolution
I was talking about before
and then integrating
over the possible states, yeah?
The costs for each state,
and figuring out our J,
figuring out a way
to minimize that.
I only wrote that down
to make it look hard, OK.
It turns out, again, just like
before, the recursive form
is beautiful and simple, OK.
So you can imagine doing it
that way, and that's correct,
but just like before, the
dynamic programming solution
exploits the recursive--
the additive form
and does a recursive
solution which
just works out beautifully, OK.
So if I do J of x from time 0
being the expected value of,
let's do the final cost also,
then what's J of x capital N?
My cost to go, given
I'm at the goal.
The time has expired,
and I'm at state x.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] h of x.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Is it
expected value of h of x,
or is it just h?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: h is
[? deterministic ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
Yeah.
If I know I'm already in x, then
there's no probabilities left,
yeah.
OK, and then if I go
backwards, J of x at time k
is going to work out
to be min over u--
I should say J star of x.
Sorry.
J star of x is going to be min
over u the expected value of g
x, u plus J star of f
of x u w of n k plus 1.
Can you buy that?
OK, so the reinforcement
learning people always
like to say that the
reward or the cost
can also be a random
process a random variable.
I'm always in this case
where I design the cost,
it's a function of some random
x, but g is deterministic.
So actually, I could take that
expectation right inside here,
and I just have
to do a min over u
of g of x times the expected
value of my cost to go, OK.
The nicest way to see how
to implement that is let's
go ahead and--
we've already discretized time.
Let's discretize
state and actions.
So now I have S of n plus
1-- remember I switch
to S's and a's when
I discretize things--
is now f of S n times some
action times my noise.
And the advantage of
discretizing stat and actions
is now I can do P of n plus
1, which is a function of S.
I could think of
that as just a vector
where the ith element is the
probability that S of n plus 1
equals Si.
Is that OK?
The probability distribution,
remember, in general,
was a function.
In the particle in a bowl case,
it was a continuous Gaussian
function.
If I discretize the
state there, then I
can represent that
as a vector, saying,
what's the probability of
being in state one, what's
the probability of being in
state two, probability of being
in state three, and so on, OK.
So the reason to
discretize states
is I can turn my continuous
function into a vector.
Yeah.
And I can turn this function
into a transition probability
matrix.
I can-- so f goes to Tij, which
is the probability of landing
in Sj--
I should-- it depends
on the actions--
given I was in Si
and I took action a.
This is a matrix.
It's the transition matrix.
And now the state
distribution dynamics
are going to just turn out
to be a pretty simple matrix
equation.
That's in-- oops.
Tij Pj at time n plus 1.
Yeah, so let me actually write
the whole vec-- the real vector
form.
That's really for-- that's
for a single element of it.
I could just write, if I'm
doing it in column vectors,
then it's actually going to
be P of n times T of a, OK.
Where these two are
vectors, that's a matrix.
So and this is
the discreet time,
discreet action, discreet
state master equation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: I use
it as a column vector.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Let's make sure.
So the probability of being in
state J given I was in state i
should be the sum over--
write this thing.
Probability of
being of S n plus 1
is a probability-- what's that?
I think I had it right, right?
It's not a true loop,
but I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: [? Don't ?] [? you ?]
[? need a ?] transpose?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: I
need a T transpose?
AUDIENCE: Get a T transpose.
AUDIENCE: You just
can't hit the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, of
course, because I did this.
OK, yeah, so sorry.
Yeah, I think the way I've
got T defined-- but thank you.
That should be a
transpose, yeah.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
T transpose
on the other side [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: In which case,
I could have written it
with the T as a
transpose too, but if I
transpose the whole thing.
Doesn't really matter if you
like row vectors or column
vectors.
The point is the
master equation,
which looked a little
scary before, yeah, turns
into a simple matrix update
in the discrete time,
discrete state case.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in this
[INAUDIBLE] [? truncated ?]
[? the actions ?] or you'd
just not [? capture things? ?]
Because you have hard limits
if you discretize things.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So there's a
question again, just
like we had the
question when we did
dynamic programming for
the value iteration,
of how you go from the
continuous probabilities
and continuous states
back to the other one.
So again, yeah.
So I would sample
for my Gaussian
and fill out a
transition probabilities
as a close, truncated
representation of the Gaussian
and still interpolate with
the barycentric interpolators.
And now the DP update works
out to be just a simple.
The probability of being in S--
let's see S--
J is the min over a.
The expected value
from this equation
can be taken care of
with just the transition
matrix over here.
And I get maybe
my vector g of a,
which is the cost of
being in each state
given I took that action, sum
over j Tij Sj J of Sj k plus 1.
Yeah?
And I get rid of my expected
values by just using that--
working directly with
the transition matrices.
i on this side, j on the side.
Many apologies.
This turns out to be exactly--
the reason I said, basically
no more expensive to solve
than the deterministic
case is we
already used this form
when we were doing
the barycentric interpolation.
Because our problem in
the dynamic programming
originally was that
when we started
simulating this thing
from one node forward,
it didn't end up--
unless you were
very, very lucky,
it didn't end up right
on top of another node.
So we already had
said that we're
going to estimate
the new cost to go
as an interpolation
of the neighboring
points, of the value of the
neighboring points, where
that weighting came from the
barycentric interpolators, OK.
We're doing the
exact same thing now.
In fact, you could
actually think
of the barycentric
interpolators as turning
your deterministic problem into
a stochastic problem, where
the probability of going
into each of these neighbors
is the interpolant, OK.
So the reason the
barycentric works beautifully
is that it turns the
deterministic case
into a stochastic case.
Yeah?
And that's why I wanted to say
that it's no more complex, OK.
T might be more--
have less 0s than
in the general case.
If maybe-- with some
probability distribution,
it might be that I have to worry
about hitting a lot more nodes.
So it might take
few more cycles.
But the equations are the
same, and my MATLAB code
is the same, OK.
Simultaneously, or
maybe conversely,
this helps-- actually
tells you why
we have problems with the
barycentric interpolators.
This is the-- remember,
the fundamental problems
with the barycentric
interpolators
is that things leaked away
from the nominal trajectories,
and we had our chattering
happening in the--
and our bang bang solution
wasn't quite right.
Because now you
can think of it as,
is my deterministic
problem assigning
some probability of going
to each of these neighbors?
And you can see that
that distribution's
going to start slipping away
from the nominal trajectory.
OK, excellent.
So this is actually
very important.
Stochastic optimal control
is a beautiful thing.
If I can model the disturbances
in any reasonable way,
then I can get better policies
by explicitly reasoning
about them.
And just like we said
dynamic programming
for low dimensional
problems solves
all these really hard
problems that are analytically
intractable and
things like that,
it can even solve a
stochastic problem
with almost no more work, OK.
The low dimensional problems,
even complicated ones
with complicated distributions,
DP can do the work for you.
OK.
So a few more things to say.
There's one particular
result, which we already
mentioned early, that
I have to mention here.
This dynamic
programming update, we
use this in our analytical
optimal control, too.
We use this as the basis
to start designing things
like our LQR controllers that
we turned it into the HPJ.
And in the finite time
case, we didn't even
turn it into the HPJ.
We just started-- we started--
we can back this out with
dynamic programming, OK.
So we can actually
use the same thing
to analytically try to
design some controllers
for stochastic
optimal control cases.
And just like in the
deterministic case,
there's one outstanding result
that everybody knows and uses,
and that's the linear quadratic
regulator with Gaussian noise.
LQG is the shorthand.
There's two forms of it.
One of them is Gaussian
noise also on the sensors,
but let's just
worry about the case
where we know there's no
uncertainty in the sensors,
only the dynamic noise.
So x n plus 1 is a.
It could be a of n.
It could be time varying or not.
xn plus B n u of n plus wn.
Cost function, again, is
the quadratic regulator.
What do you think's going
to happen with that problem?
Someone who hasn't
used it extensively
in your work, what's going to
change about our LQR solution?
Think about stabilizing the
pendulum or something, OK.
Let's say we're doing optimal
control on the simple pendulum
linearized around the
top, and now there's
disturbances bouncing me around.
How would you act
differently given
some model of disturbances
in the linear case?
How would you act
differently if you
know that somebody's going
to be bumping me around
with a mean 0?
Let's keep w mean 0.
How would you act differently
if you're a simple pendulum
around the top?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Anybody
else want to weigh in?
AUDIENCE: Increase your gain.
RUSS TEDRAKE: What's that?
RUSS TEDRAKE: You might
increase your gain or something
like that, you'd think.
Yeah, it turns out you
wouldn't act different.
It's one of the most
surprising results, I think,
of stochastic optimal control.
It turns out that
you work it all out,
you put your costs like this,
you wouldn't-- you don't turn
your gains up because of the
disturbances or anything like
that.
The optimal solution
for the stochastic case
is the same policy as
the optimal solution
for the deterministic case, OK.
It's also true in
continuous time.
R inverse B transpose S of n x.
Yeah, it's the same B of n here.
Did I write something funny?
AUDIENCE: Did you know that
that clock isn't moving?
RUSS TEDRAKE: No, I didn't.
Am I way off time?
AUDIENCE: It's about 4 o'clock.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Thank you for telling me that.
I thought I had time.
Nice.
AUDIENCE: Is the S the same?
RUSS TEDRAKE: This
S is the same too.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Good.
The S I wrote here
is the same, OK.
That is the same S that you
get from the Riccati equation,
but the total cost
is bigger in the--
so the policy is the same, but--
so how much time
do I really have?
Do I have negative
time already, or am I--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, kind of.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Sorry.
OK.
But J of n--
I thought it was
just very exciting--
is this plus some expected
value of the noise.
I was going to keep going
for a long time, probably.
OK.
So it's the same S
that you had before,
but the cost to go that
you get is actually higher,
in a way that you might
expect with-- it actually
depends on the cost on the
other S. And so the S of n
comes from the deterministic
Riccati equation,
but the cost to go gets bigger.
Yeah?
So that's one of the
most surprising, I think,
results from stochastic optimal
control, is that in one case,
it tells you it's OK to do
deterministic optimal control,
yeah.
In most cases, it's not OK.
It won't give you
the same thing.